[Music]
when you sold your house bart did you
have like real estate agents like
showing it to people and everything all
the usual the one in l.a yeah or any of
them yeah yeah they have to show people
how does that work they just do like
open houses and then like yeah usually
they'll set up like a open house it's
almost like a quinceanera for a house
everybody come and [ __ ] the house and
then everyone who wants the [ __ ] good i
want to go away and then everyone where
kids and ears you go to no how is that
like
in the areas i thought that's what
kensington is like my daughter's 16 who
wants to [ __ ] her in the village people
are like let's go that's not how that
works no one tries to [ __ ] your daughter
in a casino really why is there a
quarter of them like you get like cars
and [ __ ] for your birthday there's like
accordions and stuff
no no one's trying to [ __ ] your daughter
yeah the mariachi have you ever been to
a consumer never
okay all right we'll continue with what
you're saying about the house
it's a party time baby
maybe i got mixed up can we in the lower
third can we just put quinceanera expert
bar kwon isn't that cool with you guys
i thought it was the village they're
letting i thought they're announcing to
the to the village like i mean now it's
a modernized version of it right so the
old school version like now it's the
[ __ ] like my daughter
kiss begins with kate version of
quinceanera but the original quinceanera
is like hey my daughter is of age
everyone
come do your time so here's everybody at
a quinceanera right
right here's barnard quinceanera
[Laughter]
he's just limbering up he's getting
ready he's like old enough for kisses
so he's in line for cake and doesn't
think that that's what it's for so this
is the back but that's what they do and
then they open the house up and you get
a bunch of people come in and then
usually they'll like a couple people put
in an offer or some people just go
do one of those things tire kicker yeah
yeah yeah then check it out knock out
the door look at the oven mm-hmm
and then hopefully you get like an offer
or something yeah
that's a real estate expert marquan i'm
both quinceanera and real estate that's
good cool easy chiron no problem
that sounds correct this is uh
this is one way that it wasn't correct
these two real estate brokers in the
hamptons
um
they were uh chosen by a client to have
their home be sold
and then when the broker said okay we're
gonna do an open house on this day and
this day
rather than do an open house the two
brokers basically just [ __ ] each other
in the bedroom
they're really [ __ ]
you know that's happening whoa
you know that shit's happening a lot you
know what it is the two brokers it's
like real estate sex
but but if they said they're gonna do an
open house do they actually do an open
house and just want to get caught like
it's like some weird they said it would
be an open house and instead like when
the owner i guess checked cameras that
the brokers weren't aware of
that's when they were uh confronted it's
like a mansion huh it sounds like some
baller it's a baller place there's
something sexy too about you're in an
empty place like i remember when i was
leaving my koreatown address and i had
my ex in there and we just [ __ ]
pounded one out and broke it we did we
did it in your korean tower place my
koreatown place that was pretty nice no
it was a piece of [ __ ] but it was empty
it was looks kind of like different
because of where we were in chat what
were the uh genders of the two uh
brokers male and female both straight
and they were kind of like power brokers
in this like field they had reputations
do you think that hurts their reputation
moving forward um yeah this one does i
think i disagree with you right i think
this actually promotes their business
even more i think it elevates them to a
whole nother it humanizes them exactly
people [ __ ] people real estate agents
are people too man and i think you're
kind of being insensitive so next time
you host you should probably think about
that i would i would i think if it was
like a specific type of clientele i feel
like this
these types of clients would prefer this
that not happen i think if you live in
the hamptons you deserve it a little bit
or now the next guy's over is like um
hey brokers come try to sell my house
and do an open house and then they're
purposefully setting up cameras and
stuff like oh actually i don't want to
sell anymore now i got this footage they
start beating off to it
so yeah are they do they take [ __ ]
pictures of your place like when you're
selling that yeah each time we've sold
they they take a [ __ ] ton of pictures do
they do drone shots and all that kind of
[ __ ] too sometimes it depends on like
the the agent guy that or girl that's
listing and what they think what they
think they need to sell it with yeah
yeah or i'd like that them like our
first home was like our starter home
they didn't go like the whole night but
the first one was your forever home then
your second home was your forever home
our first forever home um no drone shots
i think that was more like uh like
regular family demographic the second
forever home was more upscale so they
have to do the drone shots or else the
clientele will literally go on like a
website and go no drone shots don't even
want to look at it that's a new level
whoa that's like a standard yeah yeah
it's a standard like i've seen him
everywhere now because because we were
just selling our place like you know
[ __ ] eight months ago or some [ __ ]
and yeah i i i mean we're in a complex
so it doesn't matter that much condo but
in
houses now you see the drone shots
everywhere for bigger houses are the
drones inside the house some of them
some of them will do a steadicam inside
and then even just the service is
different like some some of them like
you just go to like a baller house it's
like just champagne like ready yeah
versus like a like a regular home it's
like oh everyone you want water you want
water it's just this like just i think
they're servicing that demographic
trying to wine and dining yeah it's just
crazy so here's some fun details about
they should post the [ __ ] sex video
on pornhub well that's the thing they
didn't actually get the the sex video
what they did get is video of the two of
them entering the bedroom
and then exiting the bedroom with less
clothes 39 minutes later
oh hey good for the guy hey good for the
guy good for the guy that's not easy 39
minutes that's on you that's on you so
what happens here so who won the bid
hey also was she dressed as a real
estate lady
that's what i was gonna say you do like
this when
the girl leaves and the guy clothes
oh you're a property sex guy huh and
then the guy comes out naked with
clothes that don't he's like holding
in a little blazer
and he's holding his heels over his
shoulder
oh yeah smoking a cigarette i
so he gets confronted by the owners
about the video do you play dumb what
are you talking about what do you think
he would never do that what do you think
he did what are you doing
did he just flat out denies it yes what
else any other i think he's probably
like
um i'll take less commission
bingo wow that's it this guy watched
yeah that's confronted with the
information
uh the dude confessed using the bedroom
for a sexual encounter and he offered to
continue the listing with zero
commission and fulfill his fiduciary
duties under the exclusive contract
that's pretty good man dude he also
offered to rent the condo personally to
offset the defendant's financial damages
and he guaranteed he wouldn't [ __ ] it
that's what it says
dude if i'm selling a house yeah that
guy's experience you're gonna [ __ ] my
house so you don't i don't have to pick
they also didn't go for that they ended
up settling they they uh sued settled
out of court but we know all the
information so like how good was the
settlement like we're already talking
about it that much of it could go it
could go out but yeah the nda
they can't talk about anything else you
guys are thinking about how people
[ __ ] in your house before because you
like unless you had a new build yeah
people were [ __ ] in your house well i
think [ __ ] your house is different
than [ __ ] in like your bed that's
true well but in the same area where
your bed is probably logistically with
the way you can set up so their
[ __ ] essence spirit was still there but
that's no different from like a hotel
right yeah i feel that the most in a
hotel like sometimes i'm just like
should i even be touching the walls yeah
i'm like i know they don't clean the
walls and [ __ ] it's probably jizz all
over this place there it is oh my god
[ __ ] it have you ever just done a hotel
wall no i don't think a lot of people
have either
did you say you kissed the wall
nope i'm like
hold up kisses
it's stupid it works every time it's
unbeaten
that's 10 for 10 though i laugh every
[ __ ] time yeah
so this dude he's no small fry man the
uh the guy he he's had sales of homes
that were like 72 mills oh my yeah why
are we just talking about the guys is
the girl not a broker too we don't need
to talk about that
yeah she is a broker yeah 72 million uh
yeah let's see what his commissions look
like
food in 2020 he sold one for 72 million
it's good because dude if he sells the
house this is the type of checks he gets
whoa
on that house on one transaction that's
crazy that's why he has to get his rocks
off and different so if sophia if the
owner of that house hypothetically 72
million dollar house would have taken
that deal to be like all right fine i
won't take commission he's like i'm
having sex for two million dollars right
now
that's crazy
yeah like sick yeah i'm gonna hire him
the whole reason that they even decided
to check cameras and all that is because
their home was not getting any offers
so they were like suspicious about what
these people were really doing because
they had like 20 open houses and there's
no [ __ ] offers
it smells like [ __ ] all the time the
neighboring home had offers around that
time and they were wondering why don't
why are these guys getting offers the
neighbors and we're not you're supposed
to be good brokers
wall street and he's like he's like i
don't know [ __ ] the clients
yeah dude you want to make it this game
take cocaine you got a jerk off you got
a [ __ ] in the house that's why he's
the champion dude
this guy's great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you